je suis moi-même l'un des assassins de
mon propre fils elle est forte homme aux
femmes alors je suis moi-même l'un des
assassins de mon propre fils il y a
plusieurs personnes sur terre
donc c'est un homme si on essaye un
petit peu en acteur oui non
mais ce serait une bonne idée mais non
est-ce que c'est ironique ou est-ce que
non pas du tout c'est Pierre Arditi qui
a dit ça dans une interview et il
reconnaît que il y en a d'autres hein
Gérard Jugnot dit qu'il va quasiment
plus son fils et lui dit que son fils
pareil le vote quasiment plus bah
regardez ce qu'il a dit tiens au repas
l'un des assassins de mon propre fils
j'appelle c'est assez violent comme
expression mais quand il est venu au
monde sa mère et moi ma première femme
nous étions en tient en train de nous
fabriquer nous-mêmes comme acteur donc
il n'a pas eu
ce que un an ce qu'un enfant attend de
son père et sa mère et oui
vraiment Alex qui m'a donné un truc à
manger pendant la pub
pendant le magnéto soit pro là-bas
et non ma question est suivante moi je
m'étais toujours dit dans la vie tu peux
pas être sur deux autoroutes soit tu
prends l'autoroute professionnelle soit
tu prends l'autoroute moi vous permettez
moi j'ai pris la professionnelle
je suis arrêté à quelques péages et la
personne elle s'est pas prise je suis
seul et dépressif mais ça fait les bons
choix
[Musique]
même tu vas être parfait à 100 % dans
tout ce que tu entreprends mais c'est
une c'est une jauge à avoir visiblement
tu tournes tout le temps tu te fais un
nom ton fils tu le vois jamais c'est
difficile d'être bon et moi j'ai un peu
de théorie là-dessus je pense que les
numéros 1 dans plein de secteurs cinéma
télé sport en fait par définition pour
être numéro 1 faut tellement être à
200%, vous mettez jusqu'au soir sur ton
ambition ta carrière ton taf ton énergie
que tu peux pas être obligatoirement un
bon moment mais ma question c'est alors
est-ce qu'il faut faire un enfant je
suis désolé c'est pas de la lèche du
tout mais Cyril on peut dire qu'il est
comme au top dans cette il est avec ses
enfants H24 et ben il fait pas
au boulot
ma question est suivante pour qui veut
répondre quand on connaît quand on sait
que toute ta vie tu vas en fait la
passer à essayer de de récupérer une
blessure d'enfance quand tu sais que tu
as une vie comme ça est-ce que tu fais
un enfant voilà c'est top mais c'est un
vrai vrai débat ils sont rares ceux qui
ont réussi à maintenir un semblant de
lui faire Belmondo a réussi grosso modo
obtenir une cellule familiale et un mec
comme Bourvil a toujours fait pour le
coup lui l'un des rares à faire une cote
maltaisie entre les deux mais c'est vrai
que le Fils de l'homme catastrophe le
fils de tu prends des écorchés
avec tout ce qu'on a entendu moi j'ai
pris l'exemple sur les enfin les
mauvaises exemples j'ai essayé de les
mettre de côté et pas de reproduire toi
tu étais tout le temps tout le temps à
droite et à gauche avec tes gars là
ouais
j'étais toujours en spectacle aux
États-Unis donc il y a quand il y a la
distance c'est un problème dans 10 ans
lire à Europe 1 pour dire mon père je
lui parle plus ou je te le dis ce qu'il
a fait pour elle elle est très bien
contente maintenant
il a pas vu les sacrifices pour qu'il
puisse avoir une belle école
j'étais pas assez présent et moi j'ai
pas eu l'impression de pas être assez
présent voilà c'est tout et puis c'est
pas une question forcément Darty c'est
pas une fils de routier qui voit pas
beaucoup leur père parce qu'il est temps
sur la route mais bien sûr qu'il y a un
effet de loupe
quand tu es une grande star et que tu es
souvent pas là effectivement
le problème c'est que là
il a fait comme ça tournait vers moi tu
sais et tu sens que tu es dans le bus et
la personne à côté de votre parler elle
t'agace et voilà qu'est-ce que vous
pensez et voilà on a tous vécu dans
l'avion à Paris Nice à Paris Nice tu
sais tu sers ta ceinture tu en as pour
1h10 là tu es assis tu es un mec à côté
qui sort un peu et ça pas Nouna
il a vraiment dit ça alors toi tu prends
un bouquin que tu dis pas voilà non mais
sinon sans déconner les sympas et tu
fais des réponses avec toi il est sympa
comme ça sur la conversation et quand tu
fais avec Mathieu tu arrives tu as un
bleu la cuisse qui te tire la cuisse
comme ça
non non j'ai pas peur
on volé ensemble je sais pas on allait
dans un pays je sais plus il m'a dit
pour toi c'est la catastrophe parce que
si on s'écrase pendant ce vol demain ça
sera la une Mathieu Delormeau est mort
et on passe 18 tout en bas il était
accompagné de Jean-Michel maire
c'est horrible il me dit
c'était l'ancien Mathieu 2022
on dira Mathieu Delormeau est mort avec
l'autre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est mort le jour et le jour de la mort
de Johnny Hallyday c'est quand même
il y a 2 ans non non